hey all right hi everyone we are early
because leeks happy and I guess Joey and
then people are quick to turn things on
on a server which is good on them
they're just I guess the switch right
now they are so fast turns out over
watches newest hero
brigetta if I'm saying that right
Brigitta Brigitta Brigitta it's like
Vegeta but Brigitta which is weird
because we wanted to say Bridget this
whole time I mean that's why it was
written she's out in the wild I'm gonna
fix this picture and picture your
location because it's not where we want
it to be but we're gonna check her out
she's on PTR only on PC she's the newest
support here okay hero number 27 27 um
so we're gonna check her out she is the
daughter of cure Bjorn if I have that
correct yes developer updates also out
so you can check that out but if you
want to see game play and whatnot we're
gonna try to do that or does she have
skins and stuff just to check out nurse
or avatar icon there with broken it
seems like they did this really really
quickly
so there's what's her weapon can you
even click that you can okay so that was
in the pictures right so yeah if you
guys remember the photos or the pictures
that they put up on their twitter her
hammer was actually in there and
according to the to the like the
blueprints or whatever this hammer will
actually swing upward until like almost
an axe looking thing okay and she can
use that as a as a flail so she'll be
able to like swing it forward well find
out yes go find out hopefully it's gonna
be real lock is this like a 66 more
action every April are you are youing
arcade where you can get a little
alright nice yeah this is basically
every uh yeah is gonna be fun every
character release PTR ever yeah
66 everything which is awesome though
it's cool to see that there's gonna be
you know a new hero and its support we
were thinking maybe another tank but you
know support give the support some love
which is cool and I'm glad we got in now
I let me preface this because it's
feel like this happens every stream yeah
this is a PTR and I wouldn't be shocked
if we get kicked a couple times and put
back in the keys room I hope that's not
the case but who knows we'll have to see
so thank you guys all for tuning in on
YouTube GameSpot's as well as I think
we're on periscope Twitter today - oops
that's not what I wanted I want this oh
yeah where should I put this picture in
picture joke tell me left top left
I'm gonna fix that real quick and hope
that I don't crash anything while I do
it
let's just let's see if we can go into
just a quick test game alright you do
you well I do me oh no spectator no I
just want are you joining like a custom
game yeah so just one that's at least
you got into it well there's so many
people in the queue now okay alright see
if this works it should work I think
yeah yeah all right woo okay is that
Leona no it's not oh please God um man
chat this is what happens every time
Joey I feel like what it's just like
chat starts to go crazy
another support every I think it's cool
to have another support you know no we
don't even know how to play I have no
idea you have no idea how she plays like
Moira uh ended up being like really
solid I feel like you know she could do
offense and defense yeah
so it's hard to say brigetta every hit
that we get there can do come on
fill er up this is what happens when
you're first sometimes we're gonna get
in a game we're trying 100% Oh people
keep leaving this one support hype and
see only this only the people that play
support would be hyped but the character
quit looks cool I like it she's also
been in like the Rhinehart short yeah
and I guess she's been in a comic as
well so it's not
the first time you've seen her but yeah
just like yard apparently I am now the
oh you're the hoarding this
alright let's hope it works go to the
practice range we could do that too it
doesn't work can't even get into
practice range that was what someone
wrote into an overwatch someone said he
did I have to say a good job to Blizzard
though that was some quick because like
that's some quick recovery time right
like the it went from the leak which was
like around like I don't know early 98
or sorry late 9 a.m. 10 a.m. to like now
just flipping the switch I mean
obviously they were ready though like
they like and I don't know maybe I'm
just giving them more credit than they
deserve but yeah Zach bro if you can see
in the bottom left there's a guy named
thief in overwatch chat that says I
can't even get into the practice range
therefore we can try to get into the
practice range here why don't you try
just because I want to satiate the chat
just also just so I can show them okay
probably gonna be wrong but I could be
wrong
yeah yeah that's what I thought mmm-hmm
damn it give it Joey okay so she is all
the way all right check you were right I
was wrong I'll I'll take that one on the
head here I should just see myself out
things to notice so she has 250 HP 50 of
it is looks like to be armor 600 like
Reinhardt or is that the one that she
throws always like a flail so she
doesn't yeah she has a flail so remember
the her hammer can extend and turn into
like a little axe why don't you do the F
one can you do the F one yeah so in case
people don't know what she has rocket
flail the first was a rocket flail a
melee weapon with extended range so it's
like think about Reinhardt's if you
could hit from like was it five looks
like five meters it looks like to be a
good spot does she have a there's our is
there right click to that or is that
just left oh yeah there's a right click
so her right click is her shield okay
let's take a look at this again cool I
just got rid of us for now so it says
hold right click to deploy a frontier
and you can go like this so it's like
right on oxygen you know what this is
this is like a freaking Crusader from
Diablo 3 they're just they're just
bringing all their no legit legitimately
like the flail yeah is something the
Crusader uses and the shield it reminds
me very much of a anyways ok so it's
like a mini Reinhart shield that only
has 600 health but if you hold on to the
if you hold right click bring up the
shield and then you hit left click again
mm-hmm she does a little shield bash
that is knocks him back anyone feeling
crusader yeah yeah hmmm oh and it stuns
yeah so it stuns like a tiny bit and
like pushes him back to cool down on
that like fight against not bad get off
me moves so it's like it seems like even
though she's a healer or as a support
character she's gonna be like upfront
yeah like oh my god it's like a it's
like a hybrid tank support now then you
kind of its instead of like Moira where
who does you know can do damage yeah
she almost wants to be up in the action
like she's gonna be swinging a hammer
and the thing is when she swings a
hammer that's how she heals Oh herself
or everyone so like you see that see
yeah I saw that I can go out yeah I saw
I saw the little cool like yellow glow
when you go back to the other care or
these guys which are dead but how far is
the range on the on the bash on bash
yeah let's talk about 5 News 5 as well a
little bit so maybe it's like gonna be
her range about it like within melee
range is where she wants to stay mm-hmm
BAM so yeah you can see a little or just
like kind of sorry I I have to like I
mean that's that's just me I played a
lot of the hablo but it definitely is
giving me a lot of the feels but yeah
that's cool what's the is the either or
is it like armor like you're born or how
oh so it looks like it's it's okay so
it's not armor like Torbjorn she doesn't
have like weird pick it up a resource so
it's only a one-time to little every 6
seconds okay and if she if the if the
target has full health it'll give her
she'll
shoes but if they have some health for
heel yeah if they have some health like
take it away
it'll just heal them straight up so in
order for you to heal them there you
would have to be hitting an enemy or if
you melee here you actually can heal if
I'm within range I'm trying to figure
out the range of the the melee heal
mm-hmm this is too far so it looks like
it spreads about ten meters maybe like
right here okay is there anywhere in
this range that I don't think so right
now
dang it so I can heal him oh you can
take some damage too right yeah
did you heal off of the melees let me
take a look how it assumed so right well
right now even lose shield yeah okay so
that heals every I guess he was within
within a radius yeah okay thank you
everyone for tuning in
use her alt someone says okay well
before we do that should we solve one
that we haven't looked at is her left
shift left shift okay
and so that's the whip shot says
launcher flail forward to knock an enemy
away from you so let's base like a
longer version of the shield - okay but
no stun no stun on that one yeah ooh
skill shots skill shots everybody so it
so that's a four second cooldown not too
bad
that's the like get away from me yeah
all right or maybe hmm this is a shield
- do damage or is it wasn't only a stunt
oh can you like combo wombo combo see
see still no they're never gonna stay
still okay maybe like dude imagine if
the the left shift was like I get over
here what that's road hog so this is the
anti road hog right it's the opposite
okay so we got ah she did she sounds
very I'm like American shoot maybe she
was raised like across the world not
just in Sweden her alt is rallies Oh
just before you read that apparently a
left shift also heals at her position oh
really
that's what oh man the chats going too
fast God is in who said okay look I'm
not just a positive
hmm maybe not I know
oh I don't think cezzah her passive does
heal at a range you did okay so if okay
yeah so basically one thing I forgot to
note is the passive basically any time
that you hit with her flail it'll heal
so that concludes the the left ship like
that someone's hang Leona and overwatch
but it wasn't Leona it's like a pull
forward her moves a pull forward isn't
it anyways whatever okay also I just
want to test the the range on the on the
left shift which is what is it called
again the whip shot Reinhardt support
offensive tank which is good yeah so see
20 meters out can I hit them I don't
think so didn't you try just no okay
that might be the max see if they go
further from downtown 20 to 20 meters
okay alright so then let's take a look
at our old which is rally okay and it
will go where is it move master and
provide armor to nearby allies this is
that so it's like almost like a lucio so
it's like continuous armor oh it's on
building okay and so I can go you go up
to 400 and is it is everyone near you
get the movement buff and the thing no I
think it's only the armor only you get
the movement similar to like a molten
core mmm okay just get to move faster
yeah so that looks to be that vesser
that's our move yeah lots of little
things yeah I'm sure there's stuff
there's four four icons yeah she has a
passive she has a barrier definitely if
you're gonna be using her is there's
gonna be a lot of things you're gonna
have to be keeping track of I'm guessing
at her shield recharge is like right
where like you stopped using it again it
just comes back over to him yeah pretty
good stuff I think that's cool offensive
like an offensive tank yeah I've been I
think there's our support II tank hybrid
yeah well no I think is I like melee
healers mmm just like the idea of that
of just like beating them up and then
also healing so like Moira was a good
step in that direction you
hers was basically like long-range yeah
orchid like goes both but like think of
like like the Pandaren in or the monk in
world of warcraft
so you have no like movement ability
type things
no like yours the best thing is the
shield bash which like is like what five
meters you close a distance or to like
you know get you back into the fray yeah
and there's no like you're your only
real escape move is to push them away
right look how much help I have right
now yeah but that was from the old I
guess it persists until you yeah you can
see like it oh yeah there's like a
darker orange and that's like the extra
armor but it doesn't go away like Lucy
yeah or or like molten core right it is
yeah one course yeah can you heal with
the left click yeah I think within range
right as long as they're here Bailey
them if you hit them with the left click
then yes it'll heal everyone within it
looks like about 10 meters so if there I
see the little pulse um yeah so if
you're over like right there they'll be
able to get healed and so as every time
you hit with not just a left click but
with your weapon then oh yeah so like
this will also heal so it wasn't really
like an axe parcei no but I guess it
like expands every time you you use it
like tank or heal I feel like she's like
a mix she's like a hybrid yeah so she
can take damage but she her main purpose
is probably you know yeah keeping
everyone alive support William Louie
says this might break the dive comp oh
definitely yeah someone said you shield
and alt does it look different
oh cool good shout Thank You Ivan that's
really cool
come follow me you can actually see
where the the shield the the edge of her
aura ends
someone's already giving me a combo was
it swing flail it was swing flail twice
hold on I got a shield bearing shield -
bring down shield you shift left shift
after so like you know go to melees
shield shield bash melee so you go one
two and that's like that's almost one
hit then push one hit yeah like one
swing melee because you didn't kill him
off two hits shield bash and then oh
that didn't work you Oh cuz you didn't
melee twice I guess really here for the
cooldowns the skins are not out yet so
you need to do to melee shield bash
melee ok so we go not way to know when
will she come out hard to say a Harley
Faber I mean their track records been
like what like you wanna say like a
month ish its I think they've they've
gone anywhere from two weeks to a month
okay so it could be close I mean let's
just say March couple back yeah Athena's
gladiator says finally another melee
hero yep as mentioned nope no cosmetic
set you know can't show any skins as
much as people want to ask there's
nothing in there right now yeah see
that's the combos that's what you gotta
remember you got to remember that it's
like a fighting game now why do you do
this Haley Sherwood says I got an email
nice try to get a game on quick play
yeah we can we can try it now that we've
kind of explored her toolkit thank you
guys I was wrong I will cop to it that
you know the practice range wasn't gonna
work so you know there you go Tripp says
I never play support but I think this
might be my new main that's awesome
decembre stop her alts I don't know it's
hard to do the mythbuster stuff but I
would have I don't know I'm sure it does
I think you saw her just get a buff yeah
so she got a buff so her her her hack
now hacks like movement abilities so
again G can't wall climb bara can't use
her rocket Jets and there was like
something about how like smaller objects
wouldn't really block it anymore
yeah signs like that like it would go
through walls basically it was
everything within that radius or
something like that okay so let's go
someone says that Genji reaper going to
destroy her I don't know about that man
like if she's you don't know how much
she's healing off the melees right cuz
like if you do the combo that you just
did which is like melee or if you just
in melee shield bash melee again you're
healing yourself they're getting damaged
like I don't know I feel like Reaper
wouldn't would encounter her because her
shield bash will recharge faster than
his tells like that goes walk or
whatever and like she she has like a 600
health shield to absorb we just did her
alt so you know you'll see it again if
you uh hold alt and bring the shield out
it kind of shows like the rally flag
like hey form up on me yeah her shields
looks a little different most likely you
can everyone else will be able to see
the ground for everyone asking we can't
show any skins not in there I gotta
remember don't say Bridgette it's like
we get that we gonna get that it's like
I just have to think of a jeah even
though it's not even that close someone
still thinks that it Reapers damage is
high enough to counter her I don't know
she can block some of it and then and
then you know maybe block then shield
bash and melee get life back and then
push away like he's not gonna want to be
like next to her I don't think it's hard
to say it we haven't seen it but yes I
like all the theory of crafting Allen
pairs a gay spot is brigetta gonna be
worth meaning because I need to main
someone badly and do you remember me I
remember you from yesterday Allen and
hard to say I mean like the beauty of
overwatch is there's now 27 heroes and
you get to play what fits your style or
you know either if that's aesthetic
gameplay whatever find the here
rose that you enjoy to play maybe she
becomes a man for you maybe you find out
that you don't like a male a hero you
know like some people are not fond of it
you know so definitely find what fits
you best looks like we finally got in a
game it's gonna be 66 probably forget
the until somebody decides to like hard
counter oh we could do that too yeah see
so people are gonna get pissed because
what's gonna happen is they're gonna be
all these people in chat that have been
saying oh these people counter forget
that and then we're like cool we'll try
doing that and then they're like why
aren't you playing brigetta it's cuz you
guys wanted to see the counters you guys
wanted to see the counters okay so you
can either have one or the other so we
got five ricketts's and one torvi yeah
dad's around
gotta have dad you gotta have dad let's
check out her or voice lines here Oh
turn it up Hey what III suppose we get
does mom must be pretty tall that or to
ARB you wanna back just like broke cuz
like dang she got height that he don't
have that one to our daddy issues
alright here we go he even said why are
you guys so tall all right let's
illegitimate child here or maybe it's a
foster parent he's a foster parent
alright here we go alright I'm gonna try
to watch the healing seems pretty good
and because you know what this is like a
hard thing to test because because
they're all healing each other I know
off melee so like the fact that the rest
of your team wasn't all in their mailing
yeah it's a problem I mean think about
how when Moira was on PTR yeah I was
just orbs flying everywhere like 24 orbs
or twelve orbs everywhere we definitely
used her emote
didn't we oh did we not use the email we
did the voice line it's just heroic okay
skillshots Oh No that's like the speed
of Ana's uh her her sleep dart that does
that block melee push him
oh she's gonna die yeah what do you
think you're gone so amidst all this
chaos we can't forget to uh to give
shields to everyone so number one yeah
to heal its shield or heal oh you have
alt which is awesome okay so oh oh here
475 oh that was our mortar Buuren armor
though yeah so that's all the aren't
dang she could be pretty buff wasn't
machree alright you he's trying he's
trying some counters I like that the guy
doing pure burn that's cannon daddy's
coming to help his daughter pushing them
all someone wants DPS with a sword
instead of some of these kind of
bludgeoning type weapons
alright so I need to know enough of if
chat needs once to see that the attempt
type counters or not and if you do then
we'll try it out but if you don't I
don't want to hear about or if you do
and we do it I don't want to hear from
the rest of chat that like we aren't
playing the new character I like this
personal shield feels nice feels nice
whoa Oh what was that
thank you oh he'll that person oh oh
this is not good
oh there you go with that they're all
they double halted well I want to hear
it oh do you hear that flag said that
the dude yes like I'm like a rally
called Oh No Oh Torbjorn with his uh he
had his alt Oh dad save dad how many
people know the shield basket oh my god
man
could you uh or was it could you show
her where is that info somebody I missed
it she's like she's like a paladin
Junior Pamplona JP healer and tank my
two main roles yeah it's gonna be a good
one
look at this wall they're building I
like to see the counter says they're for
this yeah I want to see the counter it
says King ologist yes counter a lot of
people say encounter this new hero is
like a paladin yep pretty much a paladin
Crusader from Diablo oh you got the
rally barricade up oh yeah oh yeah I
like it you're good you're blocking for
everyone oh honey watch out I knew woods
good Lockett can't do it personal shield
no he's got no thing that you just did
well side - no no I know I got knocked
okay I was like can you bash go sideways
that's pretty good oh oh oh yeah over
time they have the point though dang it
will be fine oh sweet she says rally to
me I didn't hear that earlier oh boy
can't tell whose is whose it all like
the same voice oh you're doing may all
day baby
someone's trying to break the meta here
which we'll try to do soon as well sorry
me freaking got buff oh you got buffed
yeah girl got buffed she got no no I'm
coming guys
you almost have alt by the way yeah dang
it
yeah she got buff so her own all right
here what go ahead talk oh yeah her
freeze time was lengthened like once
they're frozen they're frozen for a
second and a half now yeah as opposed to
one oh wow here so the thing that's
problematic would try in the counter is
we're gonna run into five of them six of
them but hey if you really want to see
it you want to try replay real quick
here we're gonna try it
I know chats gonna get pissed at me
everyone else is gonna get this yeah
whatever hey someone with me it's fine
we'll try for a little bit
anyone else you want us to try we'll try
mark-paul Hill says macri's trash
where's her and you need dang it that's
too fast
yeah McCree i cant macri's not gonna
work against her she's like with that
personal she had a couple options and I
can't dang it like she can close the gap
so easily with him against him someone's
saying she's like a character from
paladins paladin's rip-off confirmed I
don't know I don't play paladin so
Murphy's is you longer might click
costless oh okay so you need either DF
dia Sombra or Pharaoh
Farah dude this is what I think he said
oh we got one bath Dione here not
anymore
oh this is working kind of except you
can't kill him oh because he's healing
him this is awkward okay there was like
four of them there nobody else around
yes James and of all her alt allows her
movement to be increased I don't think
her melee gets buffed right no may I
speak pretty sure is the same okay so
let's try to get to another someone
thanks Symmetra
I don't know okay so we got a fire here
why is the one person streaming not a
new character because this is what
happens when you get requests from 5,000
people you try to give in to some and
then the others are what you have don't
worry we'll go back to her I just want
to do a little quick testing see oh
there's a Reinhardt oh he's like let me
show you how it's done
yeah remember her her shield was based
off of his his design oh no oh no it's
doing some work it was a riot I would
say when you're you're focused like
mainly focused on that one yeah we get
that that it was pretty oh so I'm trying
Farah as someone mentioned as I can you
did you try aiming the shield upwards we
need to try that oh oh
Arisa yeah okay she's gonna go down
here's this person trying to like like
counter the we got this man but then
there's a there's a Reaper they like
counter that a lot of people saying
paladin's ripoff maybe I don't know
someone said doom face we can try doom
fist later we can also try Sombra I
suppose do you think that the the hack
stops her passive he'll I don't know
okay I think yeah we definitely have to
try sambar because like summer every
time we have one of these pgoz there's
always one just like running around
trying to see what hack does because the
shield would definitely disappear yeah
like all her other like active abilities
mmm Reaper is doing some some beeps but
again it's hard to say because it's not
like well you're not one be wanting
which is like the scenario that all know
yeah well he was running past me it's a
junk right here
people are trying some weird stuff yeah
someone's saying like ashram paladin's
that's what a lot of people are saying I
guess I'd have to look that up I don't
know too much about paladins I apologize
I know they have a battle royale though
and that's out I wonder if anyone okay
the fact that I haven't heard too much
about it must mean it's a user hasn't
picked up traction or it's not that good
I don't know okay just like a firm
tonight oh whoa okay I'm gonna go back
to let's try silver all right do you
think you have enough time for that I
guess we'll find out for everyone that
knows or is wondering we're just trying
counters we will play more brigetta
don't worry it's just you might as well
find out what she can do wait that was a
junk Rhett dang it smooth watch out yeah
alright now that's like alright which
one
oh no she can't she can't use her shield
well we know that right
I thought we knew that Oh teleport away
oh you're so in trouble what we're
trying to figure out is uh like I wanted
to know if her passive heel got over a
gas fueled yeah I mean you should have
took this is hardly say Oh ten life
sorry
oh the battlegrounds not out yet no my
bed I'm so confused right now I thought
he was out I thought the battle ground
was out which one yeah someone said no I
don't I don't I'm not gonna get into
that
paladin's conversation right now okay
damage-wise not so much
all right where we are hacking the crap
out of them we just need to get your alt
and oh there's a Maire oh oh nice nice
play there oh they're about to win again
now if I can help it
that was planned no no planned that's
how you do it this is bad
all right we'll go back to forget that
okay how much damage does her flail do I
I think that's about 50 damage okay her
it took a good number of swings in order
to to take down the training dummies
okay so apparently she looks similar to
two ash armor wise and alt but other
than that nothing alike all right thanks
meerkat phantom who can counter her I
don't know we're just trying different
thing there so once that played please
play hands out why did he got changed to
no yes oh look look at the look of the
cards the the backgrounds are a little
bit different now got a little bit more
triangle shapes doom fist is the best
play Ryan please now someone saying
she's a ripoff of ash and viven so if
there's two characters hi you know what
not gonna get into it that was good
sombre play I suppose so
just hack way I want to do whatever this
is a shield block damage without it
being deployed like with it being on the
side of her hand I don't think so it's
that's not how that works
fortunately junior pamplona says I think
not because the hack doesn't stop Lucio
zora that makes sense I guess oh look at
that Chinese New Year this is a PDR hey
you have all this hey so now legendary
go away hands OH means OH
Hanzo that's all she's got huh she has
no highlights nothing ever victory goes
nothing you look at her weapon it's
about it but you can't like yeah see II
modes victory poses pretty good stuff
look
yeah for kartum 7 thanks RINO dactyl and
explosion playable on PTR right now over
watches latest hero a support hero I'd
like to think of her as like a support
that's a hybrid tank in a way because
she's gonna want to be kind of in like
you know either in the front lines or
stopping dive comps from getting you
know to the healers and whatnot melee
hero a lot of abilities pretty cool to
me it reminds me a lot of like a
crusader paladin from Diablo 3 I'm not
even talking about paladins the other
hero shooter I'm just talking about
Blizzard profit-wise yeah like just like
the feel of what she does because you
know like Crusader has an aura too and
things like that we get we get there
should have been a tank yeah I think we
I mean she's kind of filling a potential
niche role yeah you might see as you
tank we get to comp the thing is like
when I was thinking about war I guess
once we figured out what character it
was we were like okay she can be a tank
if she can be defense is she gonna be
like what I couldn't like I was
struggling to actually think of a tank
style that we kind of lack you know it's
like the the tanks that we have pretty
much everything is covered or most of I
mean until they come up with something
completely different and crazy but I'm
not thinking like oh we need a tank that
does this or whatever yeah melee healer
though could always use that I still
don't get how she's so tall but whatever
because she is to your reruns daughter
in case you guys are curious imagine
needing an off tank and you just get
brie get the and you never know what if
it works though you know we'll see time
will tell someone's saying Farah as a
counter yeah someone switched to her in
the last game like right before it ended
seemed like it did all right
well because we haven't tested if she
can put her shield yeah you know which
would be pretty it is pronounced no
trust me Bo's man go watch the developer
update and you'll see that what I'm
saying is actually the correct way and
it's not actually just Bridget fudge
here let me let me go find the develop
yeah I just want to prove because I
asked Joey right before we started
because I was afraid that we were gonna
you know potentially say it incorrectly
and so I made sure we planned for this
I made a hundred percent sure that we
didn't F this up so let me find it and
then I will play it for you you won't be
able to see the screen here how do I do
this always hear it though all right
we're gonna hear from daddy Jeff you're
gonna hear from daddy Jeff here in a
second I'm not gonna hear it but you're
gonna hear it what's up everyone this is
Jeff from the overwatch team I am super
excited to be here today because we
finally get to talk about hero 27 who is
heroes not sure if you feel it is
brigita Lindhome first sovereign sweet
in DB Ryan Hart animated short honor and
glory you might have recognized her
austere wrong boys is what something did
you not just hear Jeff actually you're
wrong booze was it booze or boys or you
know the other way we can do it too we
can have it play from your screen here
all tab real quick okay so so that mean
you can hear it and I can feel we got
here let me go full camera real quick
I'm gonna full camera then I'm gonna
show you guys and then if I'm wrong I'll
say sorry again because that's okay
yeah Alan is that no that's someone
else's oh dang okay I'm just gonna go
into the overwatch it's there that one
the one right below it
all right just so I can hear it bullcrap
that's loud I'm super excited to be here
today because we finally get to talk
about hero 27 who is hero 27 well it is
pretty telling
Brigitta you first saw I was saying it
wrong but it wasn't the way that the
other guy said it which was like Bridget
Brigitta Brigitta Rita vegeta brigita
but it's definitely not Bridget I bring
down her if any voice lines like saying
her thank you daddy Jeff all hail and
praise daddy Jeff alright I wonder if
anyone has voice lines in the game yet
that like reference her we're like you
know how they do like the conversations
before the match oh yeah yeah yeah
you've done this but I wonder when
they're gonna act like the right people
will turn off or sure how to pronounce
her name Brigitte L like Vegeta that's
why I was saying Vegeta this whole time
because it's brigita what's Brigitta
Brigitta God dang it
I'm just gonna stop saying it I'm gonna
call her be who Vegeta bridgie Vegeta
bridgitte Oh y'all were closer when then
I was stay on point trying to stay on
point man it's hard pronounced
pronouncing names is hard when it's not
what you think it is why couldn't it
just be Bridget
because then that wouldn't be accurate
for like Swedish name alright
right here you are with logic and I'm
the guy that's like oh this is fun
hey no don't interrupt our 1v1 get in
there to herbs or not Reinhard well call
her Brig
close it it's brigita Brigitta brigita
there's the shield this is like a little
strange I don't know if it's because I
was recording Monster Hunter stuff
earlier and alloys out in Worcester
Hunter but she reminds me of a boy for
some reason oh it's probably the red
hair yeah and like the hairstyle yeah
all right someone's trying repeat Eve's
oh there's your there's your Hanzo and
he's dead
keep them bring it down just keep saying
it breaky done it's like Aggie I gotta
remember you bring great death I was a
widow
what so you can aim it up still good oh
no her ultimate increases her movement
speed and then gives armor for those
around her I believe so I got up to like
400 generating armor for people until
like I think it's another 200 200 armor
for each person
Aion she is available on PTR which is
only right now no timetable of when
she'll actually be out yet in the in the
on public so of course if you have
console you're not gonna be able to play
her today
you'd have to play on PTR all right so I
am the only Brigitta in this on my team
so this this actually kind of helps with
like balance to try to figure out where
I'm supposed to even do yeah I'm not
even sure if all the updates in terms of
like you know what's happening to Hanzo
and stuff like that are in this PTR no I
don't think they're yeah someone saying
it seems junk rat might be a great
counter possibly get those needs like
render render shield or a defeat all
right now I got a Farah so people are
definitely starting to try to oh you're
dead he's got some movement speed oh you
got it too
I don't think it was worth it we'll see
I do like that animation though the flag
of the we got too many healers oh oh you
pushed him you see what he did to that
Reinhardt just push them push them away
dang man she a reaper with her as a
combo
Oh I granted there's like two of them
with a whole foot see where it is he was
getting out healed fire from your mail
like your melee wasn't enough yeah her
melee doesn't do it's not like it's not
like Rinehart's hammer you could
potentially you know like cross gaps
with a shield bash yeah probably yeah
everyone's telling me about
pronunciations yeah I just go with the
what daddy dad GF says we keep that
right
rakita yeah that's what I said okay it's
just like when I was a butchering like
was it Hana I mean that's that's that's
easier this one's got like a whole bunch
of letters there is no a in her name ffs
but that's what he said right okay good
Brigitta forget the schwa sound the
upside down e okay Ricky Ted Brigitta
brigita the g10 Ricky Ricky Ricky Depp
philanthropy aka avenging it's just
breach eat it's not you guys are not
helping y'all are not helping at all
okay um and that's a classic skin oh man
I wonder what they could eat you can
start thinking about can she kill
herself yes Nicole whenever she melees
from her like her passive if she does
damage her passive appeals herself for
legendary skins I wonder like what
they're gonna have nope there's gonna be
some cool ones I think like stay tuned
for that when game saw plays her when
she comes out proper and buys you know
gets that hot legendary skin hoping she
has like like to she'll fight I have two
legendary that have like two alternates
probably yeah
Oh easy yeah
full armor and shield stacking I think
well Torbjorn stacked towards armor
stack for sure I saw that yeah yeah
actually no I don't think it did how did
you get to 475 because that was that was
my old no but with your alt I only saw
you get to 400 hmm earlier solo at least
does hurt II give armor to her egos
armor so you probably got heed well you
can find out real easy right won't you
just you can just I mean there's like
yeah what do I want to do some metro
okay we do have a torger maybe I'll try
that far right no just thinking okay
well just all you have to do is look at
their names right yeah is add she'll to
her there I'm just I'm curious to see
how how far we could take you could take
it
Bastien what a jerk again we're just
testing for science for suckers the
people that want to know we will play
the new hero soon
do not fear all by herself
dead do not come in here
dare you
oh man mornin so nice and safe up here
is it because someone's behind you or
does he just know he just knows
and they are gonna let my alt low grav
no grab she's literally a Roland's
legacy Crusaders on Diablo 3 I still I
guess that man's Crusader that would
roll in set did I don't remember they
keep changing it every time that I can't
really remember up here
guys got a lot of help
Zen Teresa I start putting Tourette's up
okay
I don't play Symetra ever
oh you don't want it oh you got so much
life and shine yeah there's so much life
in shield Oh
Ashley nice little okay nice
entertainment back to boogita boogita
wait are we on PTR right now yes G Jade
is a the only way to play the new
support hero hybrid tank in a way is on
the PTR we get freakin there's no uh we
get that we get we get I almost up
I'm just gonna it's it's too hard it's
too hard
holy [ __ ] 400 HP Symetra it was close
there's like 379 it probably be more
yeah Winston might be pretty good
you got rally someone has a rally up or
something cuz you're up to 300 oh no
it's the own dad what do you think
you're doing oh man
daddy's going ham right now she got
mauled Oh Oh hit 500 someone said for
the hell oh yeah how do I play we get we
get PTR we get there so it is someone
someone yeah it is pronounced we get
that Swedish at the very least we know
it's that like Kaden something instead
of like Bridget yes branded the new the
new hero is in PTR you can download it
now and play for yourself you have alt
but you have no way with you oh nice you
got a little heel there plus the armor I
think we just might thank you
uh-oh not good
change shield bash feels like I'm
watching like World of Warcraft PvP just
like chain stuns Alan fair says is it me
or you guys lagging I think it's you but
tell me if anyone else is having any
problems I don't see any dropped frames
or anything or so I think he's he might
be talking about the the camera a good
delay in the camera oh I was talking
yeah maybe stop talking about her name
yeah I'm trying but the whole chat is
talking about her name
[Music]
just spam it Oh miss this girl shot he
didn't use super there because there was
no one to kind of like buff with the
with the alt it would have been wasted I
mean I guess it could have been
could've been fine let the asian guy
play we're technically both asian are
you yes I am okay I tend to fool people
though yeah yeah maybe like Filipino
yeah okay which is still no just kidding
yeah pretty much Brandon the new feels
similar to me from viewing it that it
reminds me a lot of the paladin from
Diablo II oh she does heal she is a
support hero that's kind of like hybrid
tank too though
Nance there must be a lot of Hanzo means
or something why because every was just
like please play Han oh maybe maybe it's
because they think the changes are in
for me it looks like the game is lagging
a bit interesting really no I think it's
so good
I can ask somebody outside that's
watching too in case
let me ask Ben Jacob she can't aim up
with a shield at kukoba we he did that
really quickly he didn't really see it
but yeah residentsleeper another support
here oh hey man more support I think
they just want people start playing
supports yeah that's what I'm saying
though give mores like choices entice
them with yet anyways yeah give them
different choices for support why not I
think so can you hit f1 right now on her
or can you show her abilities or no yeah
they go so someone was worried about a
curious about her abilities those are
her abilities Mora is a hybrid - yeah
that's correct James cuz you know she
can DPS an eel she's not like crazy
amazing at both but she's like pretty
solid at boots right so it's kind of
like yeah I'm being told from outside
that for them stream-wise it's fine so
I'd have to hear enough outcry that
there would be you know problems
someone just said does hitting multiple
enemies at a time channel more healing I
don't think so I think like one pause
yeah every time you just every time you
swing and hit anything you'll get that
one pulse of however much healing it is
willow sky we can give you as many boy
signs as we have which is like one like
you we have two she has the hello she
has hello she has her her like regular
like voice command and then the whole of
she has her old so he yeah
reprove DeHaan so changes aren't in
their read I mean it's easy right what
was the one was the scatter arrow one of
the arrow was supposed to change to like
a we just saw it see there's like five
in a row
what is that sorry not there we read
back to you so we got her healing
apparently someone's not happy about
Maura she's pretty stupid I both when
where I gets four gold medals matches I
guess that's fair
so you use a mold and hold right click
do you even do you have any moat oh she
could pull out her what though yeah good
call good call
oh man I missed it I'm sorry I couldn't
give you your shoutout for that one but
thank you Oh Willie Lee William Louis
excuse me thank you for that one so show
them you can point it up later yeah look
all right cool yeah just like right you
can do that oh not good yeah thank you
the full mail a cop with do we have one
diva no we just oh we gotta know someone
just switch Dylan venon towards were
towards wife molest be pretty hot or
just walking like she's really tall she
was like 2 times the height of a tiara
Tory goes up like her waist
I'm guessing Logan Hall means that this
is a hero that the healers or support
deserved
I think someone asked about console is
definitely not well I'm pretty sure okay
yeah question was teaching on console no
she's not on console right now because
this is PTR the public test realm so
unfortunately she's only on PC currently
but she will be out probably shortly
hopefully I don't know anywhere from two
to four weeks time hopefully there has
been no like actual word of like release
date so what's up grunts and I'm just
gonna call run em you think her mom is
aria did you see that could that be a
thing I don't think so
also why would they do that
stay back push the baby
I'll help that critical person haha she
got help
Oh Ann you Alton oh man it feels bad
would you both oh yeah
Oh No talk about overkill dang look at
how much armor she has like half armor I
just keep on bumping him yeah diva play
Hanzo we just want to see whether he can
counter her or not but you're not gonna
get the true experience right because my
I would guess that what that you would
think that you think his changes will
come in the same time she comes out or
in probably yeah so like that's what you
should find out if it's really a a true
countering oh there you go there's a
farm as Arya - how does she heal her
passive there's two ways her ability is
something you can like throw towards one
of your other you know companion heroes
yep that either if full life gives armor
or also heals and then also she just has
a passive ability where she melees and
the people around her was at ten meters
roughly who's over centimeters is gonna
get a heal so every time you know either
she melees left-click or uses the left
shift ability and hits that oh there's
they on a potential counter which is
what someone was saying earlier but not
seeing oh do you think that would have
knocked her out of the bolts I don't
think no it would probably it would move
first push her back yeah because of the
the whip when we throw it it doesn't
stun it just like pushes on yeah
come over here
again thanks everyone for tuning in I
know we started earlier than normal but
appreciate everyone hanging out and
chatting with us checking out the new
support hero in the PTR watch the
character origin story video fellow she
says her name correctly in the video put
out by Blizzard yeah I mean we went off
what daddy Jeff said so you know we
could also watch the origin story here
in a second if you guys really want to
but I'm sure you guys could see that at
any time so her left shift should not
stun it knocks him back but yeah the
shuttle bash stuns just so you guys know
in case your user that that move will
start but the left shift the one where
the flail goes outwards that does not
start even if you did hit with it oh but
they're all just getting healed someone
halted and I hope it's your team yeah it
is yeah cuz your armors going up oh yeah
you got all put I don't think okay you
and Ryan you're too father that doesn't
do anything did it did it not hit though
and you actually hit it says her melee
go through shields did you did you do
you know if her melee was gone it should
okay yeah any just like any other melee
shield - seems like a great counter to
repr all to take no damage and stun yeah
if you can time it right
Oh bring it on Zarya oh damn she's not
dying oh oh you got paid everyone was
out there what happened you guys were
smashing now like they decided she is on
PTR see see sore knee if you don't see
her you probably have to update it's not
road hog cook though on each Amada
because it's like the opposite it
doesn't pull people towards you it likes
which is the oil it's like the get off
shield bash through right hard shield
yeah
because it's because it's melee yeah
yeah vault yeah okay and the shield did
block the Rhinehart smash which it
should get out of here
oh who did okay guys
oh I think you guys got it this time
that's Rea she saved her alt for this
the hilarious thing is the rest of the
oh that time you pushed our way yeah I
think that might be someone else but yes
you can push her away oh I think you
found one of her potential counters here
yeah because it's I guess similar to um
I guess just like road hog whoa no not
say can't wait for the voice lines
between her and T or / right right yeah
it'll be interesting
oh well Huck everything good oh yeah
vault no way see this some around and
then they countered with their own it's
just a bunch of flags going up you're
getting the move I think it's got a stun
and hope that like they just get off
okay look out for that far oh where is
she she's everywhere man yeah that's
actually kind of frustrating that like
you can't do anything against that she
realize shield bash up there I feel like
sorry Anna is a good counter yeah I
missed the heal decay question does her
armor over heal decay no it doesn't it
doesn't knock back doesn't stop alt what
yeah I don't know why that doesn't do
anything there that's that's a weird
interaction because that other time it
look like she kind of got punted away
but I don't know if that was after her
all 20 min after her alt had finished
yeah
so what is their ultimate - basically
she gets faster movement speed wise and
then she also starts giving armor to her
teammates around her do you think it's a
10-meter kind of same thing
yeah same or same same distance so you
can see that right there the circle you
know as far as just making a kill in
here get out of here
[Music]
dang did you just get alt again yeah
seems so fast cuz I'm I assume like in a
real game you're not gonna be hitting
like a mailing yeah I guess I guess
that's true that's fair
just block it everyone in shields up oh
yeah the honor of the honor counter
seems pretty good but it's not wall this
isn't a good test because you would
never have this many on it or it sorry
we get you we get the viewing but some
people think there's no way right oh
shoot
man every time they're stopping you huh
just can't clear it out fast enough
wait is that a soldier yeah where I
don't know there was like oh come on no
oh yeah of course bring out the Winston
seems pretty good Oh get stunned I held
it for as long as I could
that's a good try they did pronounce her
name with an A at the end in the
overwatch video so okay we get that we
get that or is it Brigitta
Brigitta Brigitta do normal quick play
we'll never get her again they're really
quick there is no way we could try and
then just like leave if we don't show oh
you want a real you want like a real
sample size oh look at that you try to
counter with Sombra EMP does it work
does it stop her alt passive we haven't
actually tried the alt
what's the range like on the whip shot
that was 20 meters right yeah the the
left shift is about 20 meters does she
have a normal melee
yes it's there left-click that thing
where you saw her swinging that's her
normal melee in Sweden is pronounced
like E and E is pronounced like an a so
it is a then right brigita
because it ends in an e right her name
ends in an e for you to forget that and
go bring it back cuz that's close Vegeta
I guess so I don't know
I'm curiously the golden weapon not in
the game unfortunately guys no skins
either so yeah just so you guys know I'm
just throwing it out there so you all
know you know why there's so many people
watching on twitch it's because it's
today Wednesday yeah they think it's I
think it's the lobby she says her name
in the short yeah so does Jeff I'm gonna
go with Jeff Kaplan cuz if Jeff Kaplan
gets it wrong at least we can say we
said it the way Jeff Kaplan said it so
but we can't watch her video as well and
no we can listen based off that I feel
like I'm still gonna find a way to
butcher it so you know it is what it is
but either way I appreciate or we
appreciate you guys correcting our
pronunciation of the character it's fine
no worries if we're wrong I was wrong
about practice range oh there's no
interaction you're just trying
oh I'm sorry actually someone was asking
about the decay for her shield mm-hmm
her regular if you hit E and you give
him the like the small shoe that
actually goes away after a few seconds
but her old when you do that and you
gain that extra she's like I think it's
almost like 150 or 200 shields over the
course of her alts that will actually
remain long can saying Jeff says it
wrong
all right well watch her video and see
how she says it after this we're playing
two orbs on their father protects it you
gotta protect protect daddy here
please everyone just going past it okay
well there's one bashed in
they're all just should he gave them
armor and been a good good dad don't let
him run around come on run around out
there in the cold on hon tomorrow with
no armor come on please play the new
character we can in a second he's just
messing around we wanted to see if
there's any voice line stuff and I don't
think there was okay so the armor she
gave you is gone right because that's
why you're not 350 me me and my
quintuplet daughter's play quick play we
can try after as well thank you daddy
two orbs when does she come out on
console I don't know miles I mean if we
go by how long it takes roughly for a
new hero to come out and overwatch in
general we're hoping in two to four
weeks but hard to say they have Blizzard
has not released a actual time of when
it's gonna come out so we'll try to
click play after this and we'll see if
we'll see if we can get a real game
where maybe we get to play her and if
now we'll try to play it well I think
this one this one's done pretty much all
so I guess you can pull this short
once you pull up the short yeah I'm
gonna go full camera real quick and you
can pull the short we're gonna pull up
the short because everyone's saying
maybe if you go back and you're already
things like that yeah okay wonderful
smooth that
I know it's gonna have some of the music
from the game but just whatever is fine
in stories the heroes get the honor well
there's his wife but their gleaming
armor
yeah that's God's wife right or is that
Reinhard's wife and we're pig tricks
built them we're heroes in their own
right and I account I was gonna follow
in their footsteps but a hammer and
tools can't fix every problem there are
some things that can never be repaired
it's not enough to wait until the battle
is over to fix their armor and bandage
their wounds if you can fight at their
siding you can try to keep the blows
from falling and maybe even protect them
from themselves
[Music]
I'll be their shield all right cool um
so yeah there you go
Rick eat that and someone was saying
that was that was your wife I think
maybe all right anyways let's get back
in the game
lost viewers watching that a short I
knew overwatch here on supporting plays
as to your pay Eric it's hard man
everyone in chat wants one thing or
another you try to fulfill one person's
wish and then ya upset someone else so
what are you gonna do don't worry we are
we are playing the new hero
we've just been kind of like going back
and forth also trying to see if there
was like voice line interactions and
things like that do we want to do a
brick I mean I am in quick play right
now yeah we're trying to get in a quick
play but my guess is people are not you
know not doing a quick play but we'll
see her passive does it heal herself yes
yes ko it does
all right this is going well
what do you want to do now okay
Reinhardt is the Godfather there you go
that's what people want chatter saying
yeah that makes sense
that makes sense yeah you person there's
like five or six minute cues for quick
playing how about yeah let's just go
join custom game that's basically like
quick play right okay or no that I think
everyone's gonna be doing No Limits but
least we won't have to wait right
and I'll see start the game GZ Hunter
shuen-lu the gold weapons not in so
can't tell you nothing is in right now
everyone is so angry yeah welcome to the
internet helps connect the server yeah
it sounds my rape just started
how are you playing just now arcade yeah
oh just playing arcade yeah it's all no
limits I want to say this is faster but
people keep leaving and the the owner of
the game keeps changing sorry now lemon
party they once a new start lemon party
started yes I yeah more and more chatter
about how to say her name
how'd I not say it's people are saying
that um it's a German name because
Reinhart named her cuz him in torreón
were so close I mean that's the theory
because there was another guy who's like
I'm Swedish I've never heard brigita
as a name we can only go by what the
video say and if they're all wrong then
what can the baby reinhardt's really the
dad we're all just a fast one on us Yuto
is unfortunately no skins so create your
own game we could try but you know I
think it'll be fine
don't no idea when she'll be released
I missed the person's name I'm sorry
there's apparently a wiki on that name
for the German I feel like we're going
down like a long rabbit hole you for
saying watch the German version of this
short I'll look over here while you're
doing okay
Jacob joke retire needs to go 300%
faster and you three times damage I
would love that unfortunately I don't
think that's completely balanced
it's the EU version of watching you does
that count but it's like actually German
league no that's not it
okay let's see if we wait well I think
someone was asking about crossing gaps
right now deco says Torv did write a
letter to his wife saying that ryan gets
to name the daughter there you go
Ryan is the godfather and named her for
saving two of his life he is the dad
watch the Jeremy short for nope not
saying that part of it almost got me
where is everyone order probably down
here oh is it are you guys actually have
a real team comp no okay I hear him
acree oh my god oh my god no you cannot
be back then maybe for someone else
saying she's Reinhard Squire Faustina
says hello to me I saw it I'm from
Brazil I like your videos things hello
and welcome from Brazil or thanks for
watching from Brazil we're in America I
don't know nothing this whole day's been
frazzled I didn't even get them to
finish my other half of a cup of my
coffee coz I was like what she's out oh
crap okay let's get into the stream room
right now je oh also sorry other people
that were in here we need the room
that's a cancel like three different
things in hurts yeah we we had that we
had to push them stuff so we're doing it
for you guys
everyone here hanging out thanks
shouldn't have been there on her oh
there's a Symetra tumbleweed worth
hashtag praise day yeah I suppose I
thought that we were gonna do it like a
metal gear survive and game thing I know
metal gear survive isn't like the most
popular things but I feel like a lot of
people want to know what that's like
because they don't want to invest the
time to get there I'm sure been spent a
good like I want to say I'm just
guessing because I haven't actually
asked him how much time he's running
he's probably spent like 30 to 40 out
pushed him back on the
hilarious who did it work oh yeah that's
what happened to you huh so I'm saying
like it pushes people pretty far the the
chain oh is that the shield generator
yes children are nice they killed it
hello Baron von not saying last name
hello why aren't there live streams of
the lobby anymore the lobby as I don't
know if you saw the video but we're not
doing that show anymore on a weekly
basis we have shifted some focus to some
of the other stuff we do if you've seen
some of the chatter or the chats we know
calm chats well we call them chats here
in the office but um you know we thought
we have some of those same similar
conversations but in a different way so
you want to check those out there's a
couple outer a there's a long kingdom
come there's one on dragon ball fighters
with me and Joey there's a one-on-one
star hunter world with I think John Luke
and Ben like should it be your first
monster so that's why she is a support
hero that's kind of got a hybrid tank
role in a way yes I every time she
swings her weapon heals in a little a OE
circle that's a chunk right here
somewhere
what's her ultimate as Jillian
Pennington she get gangs moving and then
she also channels shields aura like
around her so like your teammates will
build armor I thought I thought he
exploded it
so apparently Thomas he's late said that
shield bash plus flail threw you off the
map just now that's what it was yeah
that's her all right there the rally to
me so you can see Joey is gaining armor
or was gaming gaining armor
turn on now nice lemon party he also
uses that Genji up tough yeah whoa watch
out another junk rattle oh is that the
is that another yeah he must be testing
counters
oh I'm off the point like a second is
that the new hero yes it is black cat
that this is the new hero and overwatch
Brigitta
right that's how she said it yeah how
long is her armor from her cool down or
how long is that armor thing last that's
about I think it's about five seconds
it'll heal if they're at if they've
taken any damage but if they're at full
health it'll give them armor not that
Ryan our dad real fast
dang that did like a third oh no you're
sitting it you block it yeah I can it'll
destroy the shield but that's fine
better than dying he's hunting then yeah
does her main attack go through barriers
yes cuz it's melee like there you go
so it's almost like there was no reason
for you to even shield when they're all
just chasing you you have all totally so
Farah is another oh I missed it you
wouldn't have if she didn't actually
fall
maybe you can bait someone to punt them
off yeah I just fine I like that way
know I'm someone Alton on your team I
think
no does the bad guys all forget like
yeah well when everyone's just mailing
there's no point in having this shield
up you're just gonna take damage
he's currently only on PTR JJ oh five
you can't look up with your shield so
you can block Farah missiles have you
had to you what does she say when she
all it's rally to me I believe right on
the on the other team I can't understand
I think it might be in Swedish because
you know how it's it's it's in another
language or they say differently when
they're on the other team yeah I don't
know what she says when she says it in a
what seems like a different language
though how do you feel about the hell
she's got I think it's it's fine like
she seems just lie about that much right
yeah she 250 and then she seems to
survive time because any time she's
attacking she's also regaining that
health
whatever that is that's the alternate
version it's in Swedish yeah I don't
know what she's in someone would have to
translate okay she says Raleigh to me in
Swedish I guess that's what I mean she
is Torrens daughter blackhat and
Reinhart is her grandfather flying lion
I'm reading chat from twitch and
GameSpot we're also live on GameSpot
calm and Twitter
so yeah she has no alternates to check
out as tomorrow no I am disappoint
yes it's VTR row so she has lifesteal I
don't know if it's lifesteal it's more
like just like a healing aura it's her
passive heels as she you know either it
hits with her left click melee or a left
shift yeah no I mean the lobby
replacement videos oh fly in mind they
are on GameSpot calm as well as YouTube
calm they don't have like a proper like
show name so it might be hard to search
for just those but the thumbnail is for
them are very distinct how fast as your
shield pop compared to Reinhardt it's
like 600 versus what mm how fast does it
go I think he was asking like how when
you put it up okay instantly I feel like
it's a little bit faster you see yeah
that's that's like maybe a half I would
say like a couple milliseconds faster
than reinhardt's okay
did you notice if more assault went
through the barrier her old the passive
heals herself as well as allies we
tested that in the practice range
correct yeah her alt seems boring huh I
mean if it's in line with the type of
character she is and what she does
I mean she's a support hero technically
that just happens to be kind of like a
hybrid II tank so I don't know not even
sure what other alt you could give her
from a support standpoint that armor
though is pretty good yeah cuz it keeps
going up I think it's like 200 armor as
long as it's what like ten meters around
her yeah I think about think about like
lucio except that that help doesn't go
down you don't just lose it diva you
should take that health pack I think
whatever oh my god how many do we have
on this group I don't know if you count
that as like actual healing because if
they're not swinging or doing damage
they're not actually healing oil sands
tar sands the e Caitlyn Mae is uh very
excited to go home and try her out
yep have fun when you have the ability
to play her alts like aggressive Zen
you finish her off I think so I took the
health pack oh no please don't crash in
the corner
damn gets done
oh dude do you see the ragdoll on that
yeah oh how are you alive right now okay
I think John's right it seems pretty
good against you because it's not like
the shield does not kneel is why does it
as reinhardt soul it's gonna go through
or like past yes go around your butchers
find I just mentioned what happened to
lobby the lobby it doesn't exist anymore
at least for now we do these kind of
like those conversations we would have
on the lobby we do them as like
individual pieces now and if you're
looking for them did you blow it up
there on YouTube GameSpot calm so you
can check those out I love I love how
there's still somehow a debate about how
to say her name I guess it's for all the
new people that weren't in here earlier
where we look at how much help I have or
60 I was at 475 all that junk rat oh
you're dead unless you can put them off
course
he's probably having a grand all times
like yeah keep playing her fire
did you notice every I went through diva
shield she should yeah I don't get that
that is not helping me out at all
Oh rob is a being that all this is so
perfect right I'm gonna know rob has put
up one of the chat talks Rob you might
need to put that in switch though
because that's where I mean most of
people are asking today
all right Alexandre it's definitely not
Bridget if that's how you want me to say
because it's anyway 250 185 $55 no no
like at that point you might as well
just spam atack because I don't feel
like you're getting hit by too many
other people other than maybe the junk
that April [ __ ] says Sombra is still
my favorite release just saying well I
mean there's a lot of hype going in to
Blizzcon and the way they presented her
was really cool you know like her being
a hacker and her hacking Blizzcon you
know so like I don't it's gonna be hard
to top that from me like from the
standpoint of like well you're not gonna
have too many of these situations where
it well where you have events to release
characters I mean they could do that but
then so you're looking at one character
a year I don't think anyone wants that
lord yeah as control the world says
Alexander check out the trailer with
Jeff Kapoor and then come again also if
you just watch her trailer she says it
the same way so and it's no one's gonna
call her Brigitta why oh you can block
it well someone said something about
Junger and then he wrote your bed what's
up mogari yeah it's only on PTR right
now guys I think we play like one more
and we can probably stop it was like you
guys have the general gist of it I
suppose although we do appreciate you
guys all hanging out
can you aim the bat at the bash upwards
to get to higher ledges or is it just
horse onyl it's just how would it yeah I
think that it's just think about like
doomed this is rocket punch the way she
says it is different than the way she
Jeff says it yet but it's not it's not
that different it's definitely still not
like Brigitte it's definitely pretty
tough
the funny thing is like that part it's
hard to say anything you just have
lindholm yeah it's like alright sure how
much HP does the passive give it's a
based heal over time proc buy attacks
right or is the HP based off the amount
of damage done it's it's a little hard
to tell just because when I'm eight when
you win your may Lane you're obviously
healing other people but that was hard
to keep track with so much with like
five other people mailing at once
mmm-hmm I've yet to see her all we
actually just did it just now where do
we go to play on PTR what is PTR PTR is
a public test realm you have to have the
blizzard you know launcher on PC and
then you can select in the region
section PTR instead of like you know
America Europe etc and that's where you
would play that so alright let's do this
lemon party can you show us her emoji
has like the kind of like one posing one
you know I'm kind of break it by holding
the shield out at the same time I guess
good shot
Brandon Jenkins our ultimate basically
makes her move faster and gives everyone
everyone on her team around her in a 10
meter radius like kind of like this
constant armor buff in a way it keeps
going up if you don't have full you know
armor if it if it's going down it keeps
ticking right yeah are you gonna go live
who knows hard to say I'm a console
player I'm so sad yeah it's sorry
console players you just have to wait
till she releases proper or if you have
a PC up on that way
why she look almost like a lair from
Horizon that's what I said Dustin
earlier I think it's just a hairstyle
the hairstyle in color everything else
that reddish brown with the the thick
ponytail yeah
like almost like dreads but not really
I'm not going down there
someone's get in there Godfather oh he's
so gonna die okay now he's fine what oh
he got sniped Oh someone's doing a Hanzo
oh he's he's proving to you all the
counters right now that guy has not
played her at all he's been playing
other heroes that someone was saying
kindred from League and I don't know if
like he's like a weak player but I don't
think so this is pretty impressive right
here how can i play this here it says as
David a Zonta you have to do as
mentioned have the Blizzard launcher on
PC and then switch to PTR update that
and then you'll be able to player
okay so I'm finally kill the Hanzo I
know there's a different Hans out there
to hunt design have we got a Hanzo and
then they have one too
all right like he's still there yeah
there's there's yeah just so you know
April [ __ ] it's gonna be pretty hard
to get into a quick play match just so
you know kindred is a league character
out of that job thank you yeah it's hard
to prove a counter when you're playing
against a single hero team I agree but I
mean you can use the logic behind some
of them know like the 401 and the junker
at 1 etc like it's not a good sample
size because it's hard when there's you
know six of the same hero your fight any
means but just like the stuff on paper
at least you got that he'll office or
Ajay
I like how you instinctively put up the
shield I know even though it does
nothing unless you're gonna shield bash
what you do need to do oh he's so dead
riverboat McCree six individual shields
nothing you can do
bashing them to death people have been
trying that it kind of works it kind of
doesn't it just depends oh I like how
you tried to lead it because it has that
has that travel time just like all those
okay maybe I'll use my my ultime we can
to try counter Oh after
yeah that's up to you it doesn't matter
if she viable as a healer uh I think so
I think it just depends on your comp too
though right cuz if she heals around her
and sands that one we just did which is
a hurry then like are we going he's just
gonna tunnel the Hans house so it's hard
to say I mean
my lord this guy's got all four days he
even keeps yeah yeah headshots all day
headshot so yeah her aura heals within
around ten meter radius so like you know
just depends on your team comp table but
then she also has that ability where she
can give you the feel and slash armor
attack and here's her alts where she
moves faster as well as provides anyone
with in on her tune within 10 years
armor constant armor I can see my health
is at 400 just madness now you guys are
losing like slowly losing the payload
here oh don't worry Reapers here arborio
it's got all again that's crazy
it's hard to tell how much DPS she's
doing Christopher but we were saying
like if you got off to melees shield -
male a left shift that should kill what
a 200 you as a 200 like nothing yet
nothing happens yeah
yes Andi Townshend her her passive melee
or her melee damage that affects our
passive does heal her self - as well as
their allies even what is even happening
right now I don't even know welcome to
new heroes on PTR for Blizzard but I'm
still happy that we have them Oh triple
you gotta kill that guy he's been the
bane of everyone's existence that's what
you get for not playing the new hero
now we have a road huh okay we have
fewer fewer Brigitta on the scene it's
an instinct Stefan I agree though he's
calling you putting your shield up all
the time against Meili - I would like to
think he's always ready to cue up a
shield bash but it's really probably
just instinct as fear that you know if
you had a shield you probably put it up
knowing that they're thinking that you
could block stuff yeah it's just like
trying to get into that mindset without
playing Oh what because actually if
anything you want to build that habit
because who's really gonna melee you in
a normal game Reinhard in another
briquette though quality gameplay up
swing swing the flail
I love team egg I guess so it kind of
sounds that's what someone was saying
that I swear it sounds like you're
saying I love team egg oh no you got
three oh honey it's okay yeah you might
as well swing against them though
because you at least get a chance to
heal whereas if you block again yeah
almost like when they're blocking it's
like okay now I get to do the exact same
thing oh my god now I'm on fire
hold healing all right make it count
Joey Haruna Raheem what's up Oh No Oh
someone on your team halted oh you're
almost gonna get the combo ah that's
that guys my phone all righty
all right you got silver than everything
egg lovers in the server would you say
that she's a fun character Joey
she's definitely fun like I love me like
hair cuz I like playing Reinhardt foot
his opportunities to swing the hammer
aren't nearly as like abundant as hers
well you're gonna have to mail me back
which is that's what I kind of that's
why I'm looking cool well just want to
say thank you guys all for tuning in
hanging out with me and Joey today on
the release day of PTR at least of
brigita hopefully I'm saying that right
I know someone's gonna say I'm not
saying it wrong but whatever it's right
it's right
we checked multiple times any last
thoughts Joey on the character I know
that she's not final obviously because
PTR so we don't know if any changes are
gonna you know happen but this is
probably the version that they expect to
probably put out unless you're something
like
breaking like basic like you know
consumer outline I guess you can say of
her abilities and stuff I think it's
pretty cool it's she has so many
different things let me show that really
quickly to track her abilities yes so
she has like so many different things to
do I think it's it's just gonna be
really fun to play her I feel yeah she's
also one star difficulty which is
interesting well it's because I don't
know I guess because you don't need to
aim quite as much it's just mailing I'm
just fine yeah so anyways she's out on
PTR if you guys want to try out
available there
sorry console players you just have to
wait till she releases we're hoping two
to four weeks which is general timeframe
of the last couple kind of you keep
doing things that I have to show when
I'm on full camera Joey sorry that's
alright
there's her emo anyways we're out of
here thank you guys for tuning in I
might just so you guys know I might push
another stream while later only because
we push the stream that was supposed to
happen at 11 for this stream not knowing
that this was gonna happen so if I do
that just so you guys know it will be
metal gear survive if you guys are
interested in what it looks like to have
you know being the game and what the end
game of that game looks like I know it's
a very divisive game that you know a lot
of people are not necessarily happy
about I guess in some ways but if you
want to be if you want to find out what
that's all about come back later it'll
be me and Ben djenka but I can't
guarantee you that I'm just pretty sure
it's gonna happen so thanks Joey
see you guys later yeah see ya can you
wave with her is there anything with you
all right there you go later